thank you safer and Vancouver foundation
I am gonna talk about my research I'm
very excited about my research and any
chance I get to talk about it and I take
so I'm hoping it resonates with you to
some degree it may well not I'm an
economist so we seem to speak a
different language but I'm gonna try and
speak the language of everyday life I
hope so my works about the origins of
human pro-sociality and as an economist
I want to start with a quote by another
economist maybe the most famous and it's
from Adam Smith and Adam Smith is
attributed with the idea that it's not
by benevolence it's not by pro-sociality
that societies work an economists really
seize upon this idea economists love it
now Anna Smith didn't just say that he
also emphasized the important of
importance of pro-social behavior in
humans and you're gonna see that I'm
really setting this up as a straw man
I'm gonna show you that there's a lot of
evidence both for pro-sociality and that
there's very good reasons to think that
elements of that pro-sociality are in a
way hardwired into us my work has been
attempting to unearth what the
mechanisms are of that hardwiring so let
me get into that a little bit more
deeply Adam Smith emphasized the lack of
benevolence in humans in making markets
work was he wrong was he wrong that we
actually aren't pro-social the facts of
the science are that he was if we take
him interpreted that way there is a
fantastic amount of pro-sociality I most
I imagine that most of you already know
that but in a scientific way we can
prove and people have worked on the
amount of pro-sociality that humans
exhibit relative to other animals and it
may be striking to you to hear that we
actually are at an extreme of most
species in terms of our pro-sociality it
sort of depends what your comparison
group is but I'm going to argue that for
any sensible comparison group we're out
there if you compare us to these guys
we're not very Pro social does anyone
know who they are leave
cutter ants they are fantastically
pro-social they will lay down their
lives for their ant colony mates they
can lift up to 5,000 times their own
weight they're really super beings and
and they're in terms of biomass they're
second only to us I believe in terms of
their distribution across the world so
they're are fantastically successful
species that shows a dazzling amount of
pro-sociality but what's different
between them and us the big thing is
they are all genetically related they
all come from a single if they live in a
colony together they come from a single
mother and that's a big part of the sort
of pro-sociality we see in the animal
world human pro-sociality extends far
beyond that but there are other animals
that have a lot of pro-sociality that
don't just limit it to close genetic kin
here's an example a species that's very
closely related to us genetically a
chimps now we think of them as kind of
loving and decent and incredibly
pro-social beings and they are but only
within their groups so this is quite
disturbing this is a chimp being killed
and this happens a lot I'll just move
off that this happens a lot in the chimp
world way more than it does as a rate in
the human world
so chimps are really genocide all thugs
when it comes to people who are not in
their own group and I know that humans
can exhibit that too but nowhere near
the rate that chimps do humans have a
fantastic amount of pro-sociality that
is geared often towards the completely
anonymous other somebody who have they
have never even met chimps
meeting chimps from another group that
they have not men will often kill them
on sight
if they can we're quite different this
is a puzzle the degree of pro-sociality
exhibited by us is a puzzle to
scientists and it's one of the 25 most
important outstanding questions in the
sciences today as voted by the editors
of the most important journal in science
here's the quote and it's really
referring to human Pro sociology we seem
to be getting some way towards
understanding its origins and some of
the research I'm going to talk about is
about
forwarding that and furthering that that
knowledge the theory that I'm going to
talk about today is a theory called
cultural group selection it's an
evolutionary theory of the origins of
human pro-sociality and it can be
summarized in the following way we do
not have hardwired behaviors not many of
them instilled into us what we have is a
hardwired capacity to be norm followers
so as beings when we're born we exhibit
a lot of traits that make us look for
what's the appropriate thing to do as
children before we even start to learn
that we show we exhibit behaviors that
are consistent with us looking for the
norms that our society will have the
content of the norms according to this
theoretical tradition wasn't pinned down
and why not because we needed
flexibility we need it to sometimes be
in environments in which we wouldn't be
that pro-social and others where we
pro-sociality would really be stoked up
so flexibility was really valued by our
species in our evolutionary past in a
way that's not true of other animals
according to this set of theories the
right environment could trigger
pro-social norms and here are some of
the names associated with these theories
the academics who have worked on it they
are all evolutionary anthropologists not
economists although one of them was a
colleague of mine is what I got
interested in Joe Henrik actually worked
in the economics department at UBC and
in psychology jointly not in
anthropology interestingly I can talk to
you about that after why so one of the
predictions of that sort of theory is
something that does line up pretty well
in the data that is that humans are
going to vary across societies a lot
more on their cultural dimensions their
norm dimensions than on their genetic
dimensions and if you look at these
these are two graphs of the distribution
the variation in across societies in
these two dimensions
blue dimension is the cultural variation
as measured by answers to survey
questions the red dimension is the
genetic dimension and it's really tiny
by almost any measure cultural variation
Dwarfs genetic variation across
societies and human in human beings now
that's a prediction that's consistent
with those theories but not a very tight
test of them in a sense that lots of
things could explain this so as
scientists we're not really that
interested it's a nice validation but
it's not proof one thing about these
theories is they do lend themselves to
proof in a way that most evolutionary
theories don't these theories tell us
what the right environment is that will
Stoke pro-sociality that will build it
and here's what the theories say they
say that if you put humans into a group
competitive environment not an
individually competitive one a group
competitive one that will tend to grow
pro-social norms okay why is that an
unusual theory in the in the set of
evolutionary theories about humans let
me just give you a kind of a brief
background on this and why we started
being interested in it most theories
about human almost anything to do with
humans that talk about our evolution in
our primordial past point to things in
the primordial past that determine the
way we are now what's the problem with
that in terms of testing you can't see
the primordial past so what we do is we
look at the fossil record we get little
bits of information but it's very hard
to directly test this theory because it
says our norms are completely changeable
but can be triggered by the right
environment says stuff about our
primordial past but it also says things
about today it says where you find group
competition you should find
pro-sociality it provides a very clear
pattern of what we should see more group
competitive environments should induce
more pro-sociality and this is an
interesting prediction why it's very
unintuitive not many theories would
predict this in fact most people when
they
think about competition think that it
brings out the worst in us and I played
Australian football it definitely
brought out the worst in me and my
teammates the great thing about this is
we can test it so do individuals place
together into more group competitive
environments tend to become more
pro-social myself
Thomas Fujiwara our next student from
UBC and Tonga Vanna Purcell from X
Marseille tried to test this and we
tested it in a few different contexts
and I'm gonna talk to you about what we
found first had to distinguish what
groups we were gonna look at and we
thought the most relevant group of
collective behavior that pertain to
individuals today wasn't tribes not in
the West it was firms people who are
doing undertaking a collective task tend
to work with other people and it's quite
an unusual setting relative to most of
our lives it's the one in which we do
most are most likely to pull together
and to be working against other
organizations it's very hard to measure
pro-sociality directly one of the
measures that we used is trust the
reason we use this is because it's been
asked across the world in many different
contexts ok so what did we find
firstly we looked at people working in
US firms and we found a striking
correlation and again something that
nobody had seen before because nobody
thought to look at it if you take the
competitiveness of a sector that
somebody works in that's on the
horizontal axis and you compare it to
their level of trust in survey questions
you find a very robust these are all the
points the points are different sectors
some are bigger than others but a very
robust positive relationship so lots of
things to determine how how much you
trust others many things it's correlated
with age it's correlated with gender
it's correlated with race education but
it's also correlated controlling for all
those things with the sector in which
you work this is consistent with those
theories of cultural group selection and
not much else
then we did something different we
looked at changes in competition at the
level of US states so this is a very
very
very hard to identify effect what we
found were in states where competition
increased a lot so we could look at new
firm in corporations due to a change in
basically the availability of finance so
as a regulatory change that allowed a
lot of firms to enter industries in
those states and that's the pink line
there in states where that happens Trust
goes up and it goes up almost
hand-in-hand with the new firm in
corporations so we were shocked to find
this and this is over a period of 40
years in the u.s. it's a very powerful
effect then we looked at individuals
themselves so all of these changes we're
looking at a cross-section of
individuals we're looking at comparing
one individual to another here we take
the same individuals and we ask and this
is available for Germans because Germans
have asked this question for a long time
and they've tracked individuals in their
data sets we asked what happens to a
German who moves from a less competitive
sector say from let's start at zero one
that's kind of average in terms of
competition to a more competitive one so
this is the same individual and these
are bins of about a hundred individuals
in each one we can see the average
effect one of the each one of those
individuals what you see is that an
individual who change a sector of
employment for whatever reason ends up
having higher levels of trust and these
are five period into five year intervals
so an individual who in year 1990 moves
from an uncompetitive sector to an
competitive one increases their own
reported levels of trust so we see
evidence in lots of different spheres we
see individuals who are changing jobs
for whatever reason changing their trust
levels we see across individuals people
who work in different sectors having
more trust if they work in more
competitive sectors and we see at the
state level increases in competition
ramping up levels of trust and the
individuals living in a state so these
are all consistent with cultural group
selection that theory would predict it
and again it's very hard to think of
other theories that are going to
generate this we wanted to get out a
little bit
more deeply so what we did is we started
running experiments and for economists
this is relatively new we actually owe
it to psychologists they really brought
it into our discipline how you should do
it
and we use their methods in in trying to
get at why this is happening why is this
pattern in the data so we tested it in
the lab we got subjects to play a public
goods game this is a standard game we
just described it you put people into a
group and you give them a certain amount
of money say they start with $20 each
and then you say to them if say it's a
group of five people you can donate some
of that money to your group if you
donate it the researcher I will multiply
it by more than the amount you put in so
if it's $20 if you gave all of your $20
I will multiply it by an amount for say
so that will give $80 to your group so
that's a great return for the group but
for you individually
you only get one fifth of it you share
it all equally so it creates a tension
attention between what what's good for
the group is for you to give that's
going to maximize the returns to the
group what's good for you is for
everyone else to give and you give
nothing so these games have been played
for a long time and it turns out people
give a bit but in most games if they
keep playing it they work out that they
do better if they don't give and it
actually tracks downwards it goes
towards zero this has been a well
studied game people start off trying to
be trying to work out what's going on
give a bit and it tracks down we did one
thing that was different
we took that's bottom slide that's the
standard game we just put them in an
isolated group and the other one we said
hey you're playing against another group
and your returns are going to depend on
how you do relative to that other group
it actually made it more risky to
contribute because if you if your group
contributed less than the other group
you all got nothing so you were better
off keeping your money to yourself so it
made it more risky
what are we fine but we observe their
contributions and then we ask them if
they trust we tried to see if these
groups ended up trusting differently
after playing this what we found is this
the contributions in the group
competitive session were way higher way
higher so this is they were starting if
you think of them starting with a
hundred these guys in the no competition
group started around twenty and track
down something that's been seen hundreds
of times in these experiments in the
competitive treatments they started much
higher almost twice as high and the
trend if anything is upwards what
happened to trusts will here are the two
distributions laid over each other and
you can see it's a ten-point scale but
the gray one is the ones in the
competitive treatment the white one is
the ones in the non-competitive
treatment and you can see a real shift
to the right more people are responding
that they trust after being exposed to
this group level competition so why did
this happen this is what we think this
is our best interpretation of it without
competition people do best if they
behave selfishly and they work that out
eventually in this game they work out
that you know it people might be nice
and I'm hoping they're going to be but
people start being selfish and that
tracks down they start unsure and they
converge to this selfish behavior and
they do in the end report very low
levels of trust but with competition it
can be worthwhile for you to pull
together and to give but of course it
needn't always be it depends on what
everyone else is doing so the norms not
clear we don't know what the norm is and
people come in and they're cautious and
they're suspicious and they start off a
little bit higher if they experience
others giving they give more themselves
and these are the people that we found
who report high levels of trust the ones
who experience so often by chance just
happening to get good Pro socially
motivated people with them ramp up their
own contributions and they're the ones
who report high levels of trust the
people who experience by chance people
who don't give much reduce their own
contributions and they look a lot like
the people in our control treatment some
groups tend to converge on a norm which
involves a lot of giving and they're the
ones who then report much more positive
things about trustworthiness in general
in the world so what are the
takeaways from this from our data and
our experience we think this evidence is
strongly consistent with a cultural
group selection hypothesis and a
cultural group selection explanation for
human pro-sociality pro-sociality
doesn't seem to be hardwired according
to this although the capacity for it is
being norm followers does seem to be
hardwired we look for what the norms are
and then we want to Accord and
correspond with them people can be
induced to act Pro socially when they
perceive pro-social norms as being the
right ones the ones in their group so
one way of in doing that and this is
where the evolutionary anthropologists
emphasize this is through competition
and groups harnessed this every day in
our evolutionary past according to the
theorists in this area that was a big
thing small groups competing against
other small groups for resources but
that needn't be the case today what is
the takeaway that is consistent for
today is the building of a pro-social
norm is something that some and
successful groups achieve and when they
do that they they further enhance the
pro-sociality of people who come in
without that norm that's really the
conclusion of our research so thank you
for for your patience and listening and
thanks to rob Boyd is one of the
evolutionary theorists who provided me
some of the materials here maybe best
pause per se does anyone have either
clarifying questions for Patrick or or
any any just observations or or points
of discussion that they want to raise
yeah I wanted to ask about the
measurement of trust when you're looking
at how people perceive trust is it only
within their group or is it within their
lives as a whole
that's a great question sorry I should
have mentioned that it's in with within
their lives as a whole so and all of
these data have asked about the
anonymous other they really try when
they ask the trust question to get the
subject to imagine how they would
respond to someone who they've never met
and who was in a setting where they have
no financial incentive to behave
trustworthy so it's really what we call
a weekly institutionalized setting and
we did that with our subjects as well
we're trying to elicit their information
on in the group not in the room running
the experiment not us an anonymous other
they haven't met and that's the thing
that that gets rammed up it's a great
question thank you yes what's your name
Kathy thank you I was just wondering
when you're when you're creating these
pro-social norms
does it does it matter if example is
coming from someone that is connected to
my social group or someone that I feel
connected to is there any correlation
yeah that's a good question so we didn't
explore we weren't able to explore that
variation in the data the reason is when
you run experiments like this you mainly
have a body of students they're mostly
the experimental subjects and we ran it
in Paris when I was on when I was in
Marseilles we went up to Paris and Rena
and they have a lab where they have
about 800 people that they send messages
to 600 them are students so in our room
we had only students and people who are
between jobs so mostly it was students
and they know that the other behavior is
coming from students so and a reasonable
conjecture is that we're more likely to
follow the norms that come about from
the group members that we identify with
most closely so psychologists have
actually looked at this who do you who
do you kids look to when they're looking
for appropriate behavior and one of the
things they look at is people who are
like them in physiological ways gender
and race those things actually do seem
to inform to some degree but also people
who are perceived as successful are
useful very useful in moving norms and
in establishing norms so there is there
are biases our experiments we couldn't
get it back because we had such a
homogeneous subject pool okay great
great great okay Kathy and Brent you did
you have some view from there went okay
so some of the other question online yes
question from the webcast do you think
that Trust is a good proxy for process
behavior and what are your thoughts on
whether there might be different
categories of pro-social behavior for
example depending on whether the
participant has something to gain or
give something up to be pro-social yeah
I think that's a that's a great question
so Trust has been that particular trust
question we use because it has been
widely studied and it correlates with
lots of things so people are much less
likely to trust if they're risk-averse
for instance so there's there's other
dimensions but one of the things that
really predicts trust is their estimate
of how pro-social others are that has a
lot to do with it so it's not
necessarily context specific but it
actually depends a lot on how you
perceive others would act in situations
where they don't have incentives lined
up where they're not selfishly motivated
to do something for you either via a
contract or with some sort of punishment
and that in in the laboratory has been
found to predict trust behavior trusting
behaviour very well so this is partly a
survey question that's been validated by
laboratory experiments and that's why we
took it yes you one more time and then
one more from the room so the question
was what exactly is the definition of
trust you've kind of explained yeah it
is it's you know you know measures and
the ones we're using from the surveys
and the one we used in a lab it's a
survey based question but it's been
cross validated by experimental behavior
okay great was there is there another
question from the room yeah we were
talking about sort of an increasing
competitiveness increasing trust and
I've observed that in various work
environments and sectors and firms do
you think that it is because it's more
competitive people are more trusting or
that more trusting people gravitate
towards those situations yeah that's a
great question so you must be an
economist because that's the question
we'll always get from all their
economics audience so this is a question
of selection do the people who tend to
be more trusting choose to go into
sectors like that so it's in a
cross-section and that's that first bit
of evidence I showed you we have not got
any way of controlling for selection
people will just move they may be all
assorting themselves based on
competitiveness and it's correlated with
trust but it's not a causal relationship
so that's why it's very important that
we validated this in these other
settings and one of the months the
German settings fantastic because in the
German setting we have the same
individual and we're observing what
happens to them when we take them out of
one setting and put them in another one
and then we see them Trust ramping up
when we put them in a more competitive
setting and we put them in a less
competitive setting their trust Falls so
so that's why we needed to go into that
German panel data and Germany is the
only country that's done that ask that
same question over a long period 15
years and measured competitiveness of
sectors that's why we needed to use
German data to do it but that's exactly
why we did it